ich weiß keiner wo wir stehen geblieben
waren hallo mein name ist luca und ich
habe gerade geputzt
derzeit gibt es von youtube trend dass
solche tricks und tests und ob das
gehirn das schafft und ob man etwas
erkennt und keine ahnung das ist derzeit
voll im trend auf der plattform youtube
und es gibt einen kanal in deutschland
eher das relativ kreis betreibt und da
jeden tag etwas hochlädt und ich finde
diese personen eigentlich sehr
sympathisch ich möchte den namen nicht
nennen aber ich denke viele wissen wenn
ich meine und jetzt könnte man meinen
dass ich jetzt gerade bei ihm klar
mit dieser video idee die ich hier
gerade habe aber ich möchte euch einfach
mal ein paar samples von ihm einblenden
und ein paar amerikanischen youtube
ihr seht
dieser deutsche youtuber cloud nicht nur
die video die sondern unterzahl und den
titel und alles komplett so aus amerika
dort überhaupt nichts gegen diesen
youtuber sein soll er gern so
weitermachen
ich fände es besser wenn er sich die
sachen ihm die selbst aussuchen würde
aber das ist überhaupt seine sache ich
kenne ihn nicht persönlich deswegen will
ich ihn jetzt auch gar nicht angreifen
allerdings leute bitte haltet euch dann
zurück hier von wegen ja dass ich das
irgendwie jetzt von ihm geklaut hat oder
so weil er das quasi auch nur sich aus
amerika holt und ich würde sagen jetzt
fangen wir an mit dem video is your
brain strong enough to handle wies mind
tricks die meinten die maus festen
waiting paradis autor meint hätten wir
wissen dass unser gehirn super toll ist
hier sind jetzt einige mind tricks und
daher können jetzt beispielsweise ein
paar rätsel machen und können darauf
klicken und dann wird es ungeschlagen
und dann sehen wir ob die quasi unsere
gedanken lesen konnten habe diesen test
übrigens vor zwei monaten bei einem
amerikanischen youtuber gesehen link zu
seinem videos in der beschreibung ist
mega cola kanal könnte auf jeden fall
mal abchecken aber wir machen jetzt den
ersten test hier und zwar wurde es eins
plus eins das ist zwei okay zwei plus
zwei ist 44 +4 ist 88 16 november
was hat was hat
gerade damit zu tun ich bin eigentlich
jemand der nie auf so eine scheiße
reinfeldt also ich denke irgendwie immer
leider so ein bisschen anders 1 + 1 2224
das ist ach das ist 16
ich habe keine ahnung abfiel ich weiß
ich hab bei bedarf es ist nicht das
welche table an dass ich gedacht habe
sondern es ist eine karotte also ich
weiß nicht ist apfel in wetter tempel
endete bürobereich cedric dingen des
picture dann flippte card also wir
müssen uns alles irgendwie merken was
hier irgendwie drin vorkommen da hinten
ist ein traktor hier sind pferde wir
haben eine ziege hier sind noch mehr
ziegen hier sind noch hühner da sind
schafe hier sind das denn das enden
schweine
also ich denke sind stinknormale
bauernhof also wir kriegen jetzt einfach
ich muss das jetzt irgendwie merken ihre
kühe wir haben pferde die haben einen
traktor wir haben hühner wir haben
schafe ziegen und schweine so klickt
flipboard karossen dp close to pull
wollt ihr mich verarschen
wen juckt das man also ich weiß es nicht
pink schweine sind immer bringt also wir
schauen jetzt mal nach schwarz
wer soll sich denn was ist da das soll
ich habe auch vorher gedacht dass das
hier ein heuballen ist aber es ist
glaube ich ein schaf read this and is in
the trial also perez in the spring okay
something of the sun times
ein wenig dumm
das 2 x 1
was
wieso fällt einem das nicht auf
keine ahnung jetzt fällt es mir
natürlich auf aber beim ersten lesen ey
leute ihr könnt das ja auch mal
mitmachen irgendwie in den kommentaren
aber aliens überhaupt nicht aufgefallen
wie viele es sind in diesem satz also er
mich immer mit meiner hand mit finished
the result of use of scientific study
combined with the experience of us
und habe ich irgendwas vergessen
würde sagen vier ich drücke jetzt mal
drauf und essen discounter 66
die meinen aber nicht noch irgendwie
dass es hier oben in der fragestellung
mit oder finnisch 12 a resource of style
was dort wirklich sechs ich habe einfach
im ersten versuch oft und oft nicht
mitgezählt gegen die finnen schweizer
result of heavy so wie sowieso
stammplatz nicht memory picture dann
flippte card okay wir haben es ist sehr
sehr schlechte photoshop tatsächlich
hier sind bäume dessen spielplatz wir
haben hier leute die hier rumlaufen da
sind zwei mädchen hier liegen welcher
auf der matte da ist ein hund hier ist
eine frau der hintersten jungen und
dahinten typ also wir merken es jetzt
mal das bild und klicken auf flipboard
wars nadelnde picture dobbert blanket
resch kempers
also
den fall drin nicht decke war auf jeden
fall auch drin mülleimer weiß ich gar
nicht genau was auf jeden fall habe ich
noch keine gesehen und ich bin mir nicht
sicher erhöht haben wir glaube ich
keinen trash kennen aber wird haben wir
tatsächlich nicht
ich würde mal sagen ich hab das jetzt
halb richtig hell we predict your number
picken von der leyen amber und pisse
zeigt das tool namens infrastructure
small number one number of what was es
ist überall schwierig gerade suche dir
eine nummer und dann folge der linie zu
den nummer auf der anderen seite okay
ich nehme jetzt beispielsweise einfach
die elf folge der linie und habe eine 5
also jetzt nehme ich diese beiden
nummern und subtrahieren die kleinere
nummer von der größere nummer das heißt
kommt sechs raus also 11 - 56
ok
das ergibt alles 6
c - 460 v ich lasse mich auch so eine
scheiße reinlegen bord membership kam
next also wir haben 6 11 17 28 das heißt
es ist eine zahlenreihe also 65 sind 11
6 dem 17
+ f
als lady
ich habe glaube ich 6 + 11 sind 17 11 +
17 sind 28
17.28 sind 45 ich hab's euch gesagt
bisher haben die mich glaube ich bei
drei oder vier sachen oder so nur
gekriegt wir sollen uns wieder dieses
bild merken ich weiß nicht worum es
dieses mal geht aber wir haben hier den
times square wir haben hier überall
werbung wir haben relativ viele autos
auf dem boden
unglaublich viele hochhäuser wir hinten
ist ein fallschirmsprung ment und hier
sind halt überall werbeanzeigen dass er
hier ist ein helikopter mit einem mit
dem typen wie dran aber sonst wirklich
sehr sehr viele bunte farben also ich
klicke einfach oft flip do you remember
single helikopter jahr habe ich gesagt
jetzt nelly copter da oben ist auch ein
helikopter
ja was machen diese leute da ziehen die
gläubigen plakate oder was weiß die
steeples games also wir sollen die namen
behalten wenn mike bryan at t bell micro
et hätt ich sag das jetzt mal weiter für
mich selbst auf und klicken danach auf
die auf die schaltfläche wenn mike ryan
metal band metal band namens oft keine
ahnung von dem namen gdingen stanwyck
ich würde sagen das ist das ist das ist
der erste das ist ryan den dritten keine
ahnung aber ben und ryan also erstmal
ben ist der hier komischen die das ist
okay und das heißt die vertrackten speak
and numbers between two and eight okay
wir machen das ganze jetzt mal zusammen
eine nummer zwischen zwei und acht ich
würde sagen wir nehmen einfach mal die 3
ich weiß nicht aber damit gerechnet hat
dass wir so eine kleine nummer nehmen
aber wenn ich mal die 3 multiplayer bei
nein das heißt drei mal 19 27 uhr
schritt have to get them together ok das
heißt zwei plus 7 sind 96 abstract 5412
plus 7 sind 995 sind vier hickel
lächelte gitti und numbers volks ampel 1
gleich c
ich weiß keiner wo wir stehen geblieben
waren also wir haben bisher vier als
zahl das heißt ich nehme jetzt irgendwie
fiel gleich d-link of the country's
garding mit mörtel lette
bmw habe fängt mit e an
ich habe keine ahnung aber ich blicke
jetzt einfach mal klingt slip und wir
haben über 4 1 toren
denn mag was
also ich weiß nicht ob ich gerade bei
dem letzten test irgendwas falsch
gemacht habe aber ich hatte glaube ich
zu beginn die drei hier genommen dann
mal 19 27 2 plus 7 sind 95 sind vier
dann habe ich 4 b genommen b belgien
dann mit m haben sich in any mildem aus
und mit de ist mir keine farbe
eingefallen aber belgien und maus ist ja
schon ganz anders als känguru und
dänemark ich habe keine ahnung ob ich
einfach irgendwie dumm bin ob ich anders
denke oder ob dieses test erhält dingen
ihr einfach nicht funktioniert aber an
dieser stelle würde ich auf das video
beenden meine damen und herren ich hoffe
es hat euch gefallen etwas getan hat las
man like da vielleicht hat es ja schon
der eine oder andere bei einem anderen
youtuber gesehen oder so ich hoffe es
konnte euch vielleicht trotzdem
unterhalten das zu beginn sollte gar
kein anfang eines brief seien wegen
diesen anderen deutschen youtuber nur
ich finde so ein bisschen krass wie er
für soll diese ganzen sachen mega
gefeiert wird und er kopiert ist einfach
eins zu eins aus amerika finde ich so
ein bisschen 30 meine ich die wenigstens
jetzt die quelle an das nicht von diesem
amerikanischen youtuber habe aber naja
jeder soll sein ding machen und ich will
mich da auch gar nicht so krass
einmischen ihr findet ihr einen smiley
eingeblendet wenn ihr da draufsteht
könnte meinen kanal abonnieren das ist
kostenlos und free und nice weil ihr
dann kein video mehr verpasst und hier
findet irgendein anderes video
eingeblendet ist bestimmt auch total
scheiße muss ich mal so sagen ich lade
nur kaka hoch
und ich bin müde